[Music]
[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to the iphone 10s full review so
this is going to be a pretty easy review
since we know that the s year iphones
are always a pretty incremental upgrade
so i've been using this gold 10s max
from the unboxing every day since
keynote day and everything i say here
will apply to both the 10s and the 10s
max unless i say otherwise i'll make it
clear so the template here will be
simple every single thing that's new and
what i think of it also 10s max
10s
extra small max terrible name just
saying okay moving on so first up on the
outside this phone's almost exactly the
same almost if i were to put the iphone
10s next to the iphone 10 you have a
hard time telling which is which except
for a few key things first of all the
new color of course
gold
and i kind of dig this gold this has
been a more actually polarizing color in
my timeline where i've seen some people
that love it and then some people that
are like not amused by it at all i just
kind of don't mind it but i definitely
went for the space gray on my personal
phone but this gold doesn't look bad
it's kind of like a band-aid color but
more saturated a little more rich than
that and then the stainless steel sides
are like really gold they're the most
striking part of this new phone and the
iphone 10s also has two more visible
antenna on the stainless steel band
around the outside one at the top right
above the camera module and one down at
the bottom kind of cutting into the
speaker grille so the speaker grille at
the bottom is actually now asymmetrical
thanks to that bottom band that is a
weird look you would think of all
companies apple would find a different
place to put that to keep it perfectly
good looking but i guess not and then
the other little observation i found the
camera module of the 10s seems to be
slightly larger but it's very slight the
only way you can tell is if you put a
case on the phone so if you put a 10s
case on a 10s you can see it fits
perfectly it's very snug it's made by
apple they know the exact dimensions
they get it right but if you put this
same 10s case on the iphone 10 you
actually end up with this little gap
around the bottom so the extra room
means the camera module here is a bit
smaller on the 10. so yeah technically
these phones aren't quite the same
exactly on the outside but these couple
of things don't really matter all that
much to using it it's still a glass
sandwich phone still the same weight and
feel in the hand same design same button
placement same mute switch same curved
corners same notch and same fingerprint
magnet glass we've seen this before it
of course also means it's perfectly
smart to put a case or a skin on this
one again you already know i'm more of a
skin person and dbrand is actually
launching this absolutely sick matte
black matrix skin with this new iphone
right now definitely worth checking out
i'll drop a link below oh and one more
hardware difference technically
internally this new phone is ip68 water
resistant where the iphone 10 was just
ip67 it's uh it's a big deal for those
of you who don't know ip67 means you're
rated for one meter underwater for 30
straight minutes
ip68 means you're rated for
1.5 meters underwater for 30 straight
minutes
great anyway all the other differences
of the iphone 10s are internal and
that's what you get with an s upgrade
but honestly that's what a lot of people
were waiting for you're getting the best
or newest design apple has with their
best specs as well so this year as
you've heard it's the new seven
nanometer six core a12 bionic chip and
four gigs of ram in both phones too it's
not like one has less ram than the other
they're both set
and it ended up with some pretty damn
good geekbench scores and they've said
it's 15 to possibly 30 faster in some
actions like opening apps opening the
keyboard launching the camera things
like that and i can verify that this is
an extremely fast phone as a matter of
fact i think it brings it right back up
to the king of responsiveness as far as
smartphones go it's getting kind of
passed up a little bit with android
phones of the past couple years but ios
12 is so buttery that it's back on the
throne but here's the thing
that ios 12 update is also extremely
fast on last year's iphone 10. in fact i
am not noticing like a major difference
in speed between iphone 10 with ios 12
and iphone 10s with ios 12. it's
definitely performing great don't get me
wrong but the fact that my year old
iphone 10 running that ios 12 beta for a
while and now on the final version was
already noticeably faster than ios 11
was a big deal it's kind of like a curse
apple's put on themselves this time for
actually maintaining and updating their
phones well this time in a way that
makes the phone faster makes people with
an older phone now like more satisfied
and less likely to upgrade the real
interesting part here is with the bugs i
was getting especially in the 10s max
with ios 12 i'm pretty sure it's because
of the new resolution but a lot of apps
that i use on the daily had a bunch of
like overlapping graphics or would cut
parts off in the notch where they
weren't supposed to i couldn't even read
the caption i was typing on instagram it
was fully hidden in the notch but i'm
pretty sure a lot of the stuff will be
fixed pretty quickly as phones come out
and they develop for the new resolution
none of it was actually crashing or
ruining the phone it's just weird
graphic quirks so the only place i
actually feel the iphone 10s actually
seems a bit faster is face id and it's
not even that much crazy faster i
definitely think the pause to unlock
your phone is a bit shorter which is
nice to see maybe 25 percent faster
thanks to the a12 bionic and ios 12 but
it's still obviously not as fast as
those crazy quick ones from oneplus or
xiaomi that are just using the rgb
cameras then again it will always be
slower than those because it will also
always be more secure sort of an inverse
relationship there no biggie i am
personally hoping for fingerprint
readers underneath the display glass in
mainstream phones to become more of a
thing with this next upcoming generation
like it's rumored that oneplus 6t may
have it it's rumored that galaxy s10 may
have it and it's rumored that iphone 11
or whatever it's called may also have it
next year
but not this time another small
improvement is the much better speakers
in the 10s they're a bit louder and
clearer now and the stereo speaker
effect is now actually really quite good
it's still using that earpiece plus the
bottom speaker to technically make a
stereo pair
and this makes a difference for all
kinds of media you're listening to or
music or watching videos or shows or
even gaming i'd say it went from having
a decent speaker to a very good speaker
set and the battery is one of the
tiniest improvements in my experience
they're still one day phones both of
them although now ios 12 gives you
actually screen on time so i can tell
you with my whole week with the 10s max
i was consistently getting four to four
and a half hours of screen on time
lasting all day very similar to iphone
10 not markedly much better definitely
not worse still a great standby phone
but otherwise nothing too crazy to
report here really the shame is still
how long it takes to charge these huge
batteries with the slow charger included
in the box so then last but not least is
probably the most hyped new upgrade for
these phones aside from the specs and
that would be the cameras the iphone 10s
and 10s max share the exact same cameras
and they're a slight upgrade from the 10
physically they're slightly larger new
sensors still 12 megapixels the main one
is f 1.8 and they're now both optically
stabilized and there's a quad led flash
now this upgrade i think puts it firmly
right up behind pixel 2 as the second
best smartphone camera it's a it's a
real upgrade from the iphone 10 and
every other iphone actually a little
more than i was expecting and generally
the photos are great as you'd expect and
i think the biggest change is the more
aggressive and better hdr thanks to
their smart hdr
so the color science is really good a
plus colors a plus dynamic range pretty
much every photo is corner quarter sharp
and low light is pretty damn good too i
definitely want to get another
side-by-side sort of test going got to
get this iphone alongside pixel 3 when
it comes out probably red hydrogen and
some other top dogs because obviously
the minor difference comes down to
opinion but confirmed this is an amazing
smartphone camera right out the box now
you may have heard some talk about this
improved portrait mode as well portrait
mode on the iphone started out kind of
nearly as a joke it was in this beta it
was pretty hacked together and sloppy at
the beginning but every year it gets
better and better like i wish siri would
and this year it takes another leap so
portrait mode with these dual cameras
uses the difference in distance between
the cameras and apple's software to
create a depth map you might have heard
that before so it kind of segments the
image into different layers of different
distances from the camera so when you
blur the background of a photo with
portrait mode instead of just drawing
sort of a crude mask around the
foreground and then applying a big blur
to the whole background this portrait
mode is actually blurring the parts
further away from the camera more while
blurring the closer parts less it's much
more realistic and closer to what a real
bokeh from a bigger camera looks like
it's a subtle difference but it's a
massive improvement again from the first
versions of portrait mode so you take a
portrait mode photo you go into this
editing and you get the slider for
changing the depth of field after the
fact
only uh iphone 10s and 10s max will do
this right off the bat people compared
it to samsung's live focus because of
course that's what it reminds us of but
when i compare them side by side the
whole generic blur of the samsung versus
the selective blur that keeps getting
better
it's pretty clear to me which one i
prefer and even though this is all
purely software blur just mimicking a
bigger camera it even seems to be adding
a slight direction to the blur like a
sort of radial blur around the center of
the frame which is pretty impressive so
i don't use portrait mode very much
because it's still hit or miss but these
improvements mean when it does hit it
can be pretty damn good also combine
that with the fact that it's still the
best video recording in a smartphone as
well at 4k60 plus they've added stereo
audio recording to support the speakers
and it all adds up to a pretty powerful
camera as we've come to expect from an
iphone so that's where we're at new
specs new camera same software same
design so this iphone 10s is everything
we thought it would be really honestly
the main upgrade if you want to call it
that would have to be the 10s max the
much bigger screen this is the iphone
i've been using by choice for the past
couple days and it really does feel like
a very different iphone a six and a half
inch display in a body smaller than the
galaxy note 9 i mean that's all you
really have to say to make it my
favorite iphone ever but there are so
many advantages to having a bigger
screen i've talked about them in
previous big phone videos and all of
those still hold up with the big iphone
watching videos is better gaming is
definitely better basically anything
that involves wanting a nice viewing
experience is improved i've been a big
phone person as long as i can remember
and so naturally the bigger iphone is my
favorite iphone and i just never thought
i'd see a day where the iphone is closer
to the size of an ipad mini than the
original iphone but that's what we got
here there are downsides of being a huge
phone too you can't forget them and i've
said this again about other big phones
the much bigger space it takes up in
your pocket or your purse or wherever
you keep it and it's way less likely to
be a one-handed phone for most people
let's be real reachability is going to
be way more important on this bigger
phone than it ever has been but that's
what's up this upgrade to me is all
about the size of this 10s max
if you have an iphone 10 i can tell you
right now you don't need an iphone 10s
you're fine even if you have a thousand
dollar hole in your pocket and you've
been itching for a faster iphone and a
better camera upgrade to ios 12
and buy an rx100 with that money it's a
much better camera boom problem solved
really the iphone 10s is a great upgrade
for people who have an older iphone and
iphone 7 or 8 or even older than that
then again so will probably be the
iphone 10r so i'll have to get that in
house and see if that's about it in the
full review but i have no problem
recommending the iphone 10s for those
people but really if you've been waiting
for a bigger iphone for all the mentions
i talked about and you have the money
it's expensive just like last year but
if you're one of those people like me
then this is definitely the way to go
i'm a fan of the 10s max and i recommend
it give it a shot either way that's been
it thanks for watching talk to you guys
in the next one
peace